hey guys my name is Jessica watching
games button youth and it turns out
video games are still too brutal for
Australian eyeballs as our long history
of banning games now has a new entry as
a person in their mid-20s I often wonder
what kinds of entertainment I'm allowed
to consume fortunately for me the
Australian Classification Board has
stepped in to let me know what's okay
and what's not okay as they refused
classification throughout last to the
classification board has said that out
last two has been identified to quote
depict express or otherwise deal with
matters of sex drugs misuse or addiction
crime cruelty violence or revolting or
aberrant phenomena in such a way that
they offend against the standards of
morality decency and propriety generally
accepted by reasonable adults to the
extent that they should not be
classified they added that the game may
have been considered for an r18 plus
rating were it not for a section that
depicts implied sexual violence as such
there won't be an Australian release of
the game unless developer red barrels
decides to alter the problematic
sections and resubmit the game to thwart
bit of a history lesson for you it
wasn't so long ago that Australia didn't
even have an r18 plus classification for
video games so if it couldn't be filed
into an MA 15 plus rating said game
would be refused classification as you
can imagine this is far from the first
time a game has had trouble with the
Aussie classification board fallout 3
was originally banned in australia in
2008 for portraying morphine in a
positive way so responses decided to
rename it to med axe in all versions of
the game hotline Miami 2 never received
classification and south park the stick
of truth was only classified after
extensive at it although I'd say they
handled their region-specific edits
quite well having had to pass scared of
me by our last one you think I'd be more
than okay with the sequel staying off
our shores but it never ceases to amaze
me that government bodies can tell fully
grown adults what entertainment they can
and can't consume to play devil's
advocate it sounds like outlast to is
going to be a brutal game and I'm not
entirely convinced the inclusion of
sexual violence is necessary however
surely that's the entire
reason for putting said warning on the
box underneath the r18 plus label so any
adults who want to pick it up can make
an informed decision that's my two cents
anyway but do let me know where you
stand on this one it seems I'm not the
only one who got sucked into horizon
zero dawn sony has announced that it is
one of its biggest ps4 exclusives that
even part of a franchise yes the robot
dinosaur hunting simulator is the
best-selling new IP from Sony for the
ps4 having sold 2.6 million units
worldwide in its first two weeks sony
interactive entertainment worldwide
studios boss Sean Laden said in a
statement we knew horizon zero dawn is
going to be something special so to see
the incredible critical reaction to a
brand new game world translate into this
level of sales it's really gratifying
Guerrilla Games managing director Harmon
hull strand in saying we're thrilled to
horizon zero dawn has been embraced by
critics and players alike developing the
game with the labor of love so it's
extremely satisfying to see that is
alittle to the same passion and
enthusiasm calmly gaming public that we
felt during its development pulse also
confirmed that a story expansion is in
the work though no more details were
shared for those of you whose played The
Legend of Zelda breadth of the wild to
death I have good news for new games for
coming to nintendo question this week
The Binding of Isaac after birth class
was originally supposed to be a launch
title for the switch but was delayed for
reasons are beyond our control according
to the veldt and nicholas but good news
the roguelike will arrive on the
switches ish up tomorrow for 40 bucks
and includes the base game along with
everything added to the afterbirth plus
expansion including new items chapters
and a whole bunch of hidden cool stuff
there are also switch ports of three
classic indie games human resources
machine little inferno and World of Goo
which are all ten bucks now is
everything I've got for you today to
leave me a comment down in that comment
box and let me know what you cared about
today give us a subscribe if you liked
today's video and I'll see you tomorrow
for our top five stories of the whole
week
you